yo when you saw that statue you had no
idea online gaming is Big Business
whether it's streaming or battling it
out in literal stadiums it's expected to
be worth more than 279 billion pounds by
but despite the virtual world being full
of potential it also has a darker side
with women saying the abuse they face
there can leave them depressed and even
suicidal Renata games every day and says
the toxic culture is Relentless one of
the most annoying things is when they
ask you where you live where you're from
what's your Instagram how old you are if
you want to come visit them to their
home countries and it's just a constant
cycle of like what's your Instagram
what's your Instagram new research for
Sky Broadband and Guild suggests the
problem is systemic with three-quarters
of 18 to 24 year old women having
experienced abuse while gaming online
over a third receive violent messages a
quarter say it leaves them depressed
more than one in ten were left feeling
suicidal
actress Chloe Grace Moretz Who games for
fun thinks women aren't taken seriously
enough the way that our minds work are
just obviously wired a little
differently than guys so there's just a
different kind of edge
um which I think you know I would love
it if it was if it was kind of honed in
on and and and supported more
I thought you guys were gonna win nobody
said anything you stupid
Steffy Evans is a streamer who uses Tick
Tock to highlight the misogyny she faces
online
if I could take it on a bigger scale
than it would be to get them permanently
banned or get the real life consequences
but there's only so much I can do also
taking action as Guild an Esports team
backed by David Beckham which competes
online against other teams you look here
I don't know your address
it launched this immersive campaign to
highlight the abuse female players face
if this was having happening on a
football pitch you would have a ref that
would like literally blow a whistle and
send someone off and so we can't keep
watching these numbers keep happening
and these women keep having this
experience well the gaming industry
continues to grow it seems progress is
much slower and real change is needed
for this to no longer be a man's world
Claire Gregory Sky News
and of course if you or anyone you know
have been affected by the content of the
story please remember you can call the
Samaritans on double one six one two
three or email Joe at samaritans.org